this week on the true jory podcast the
man I idolized for my entire childhood
he was the Newcastle and England captain
and the all-time Premier League top
goalscorer and his name is Alan Shearer
I had the best job in the world if you
can call a job I just had it how to play
a football I [__] get paid for it
like I don't think many men in Newcastle
would let you sleep he deserved a it was
stupid 4head but my fall was yeah
[Music]
do you really shouldn't kiss Gillespie
yes greasy deserved it really
so Bobby was whose genius at my
management
[Music]
because you're a footballer because you
have so much money here expected to
handle everything
well sometimes footballers are normal as
well
I was always reluctant to see how it was
and bees is is upfront and career legal
as I should have been well because I
thought if I'm going back into football
into management and I'm then I'm
criticized and left right and center on
the TV then I go into management and you
can look a bit of an idiot so was what I
always held back you let me down he let
the club down and then I just thought it
was it was my time to see a few home
truths and I did in the Dressman told
him what I thought told him what
everyone else was thinking and saying
and that was it I never and I never saw
him again after that they he just didn't
come back so now I didn't want him back
okay is his money but if he doesn't want
to be there and if it doesn't want to
spend then let someone else come on in
and let someone else take it over
how did you deal with losing such a good
friend
mmm no it was very difficult because I
was with him the dear before he did it
and everything seemed fine
bringing me prop motya because he asked
those last time I seen them shown this
this week on the Trudy podcast these two
fellas 20 years older a lot less here
yeah it's still just as handsome what
about you I'm a common online social to
be me Nana took that took three this was
the only one without a thumb like
because you know when all people take
photos on the old cameras it was a
nightmare
what's caught your attention is Ross
who's gone
Serena must've really cut the cameras
yeah exactly yeah it's not the future
though yeah yeah I got one one of us one
of us looks better anyway yeah I mean
you do much better I was the biggest ten
year old on the planet
yeah understand you in the you were oh
you were that I was 10 years old yeah I
loved as well as you play Newcastle in
the time when they're the best kids that
was when them Kenny Dalglish scientists
oh no I'm not saying a son like why he
got quite lucky to be a nut he's done
good jobs for the boys but yeah I was
coming down in the day and I thought me
saw I don't really know you as a bloke
like I've worship year like noise floods
from new custom your life but like when
you're on the telly you always taught my
football it also about what and so
hopefully we've been digging a little
deeper into hell why not
good luck yeah like there's a lot of
footballers who they put their lives all
over the papers and that in like they're
very they're trying to get the
personality out there you are like even
cut them when David Beckham was the posh
and Becks and his whole family are out
there you took the complete opposite
road of you know just keep yourself to
yourself good family man but if your
family what most people industry we
wouldn't know who they were
was that like the deliberate thing this
sort of yeah it was yeah I think I just
wasn't for me wasn't for them I think
you you have to keep something back
and as much as you get offered over the
years then I just think it's important
to keep a little bit of privacy
you come you can't moan about that side
of things if you're inviting everyone
into your house and everyone onto your
holidays and that's never interested me
and I think it's always I think it's
very very important to keep one side of
you of your life private anyway it is
difficult enough anyway they necessarily
don't want the limelight a minute I
enjoy it I love it but I don't think the
whole family should do it you think you
think when they become older because I
know you I think your dust when it
presented in your lives just saw that
but that should be their choice and in
the wrong time no if they want to do
that now then they're old enough if they
want to do it they can then my two doors
twenty five and twenty three now so if
they want to go down that room now then
and obviously gonna do that my son this
is seventeen and he's the same he might
he might do it more for the doors but
that's their own choice now where his
felt it was important to keep it whilst
they were young - yeah - keep that side
of it private it's just normal for that
- they've grown up with that they don't
I'm just their dad and I think that's
that's what it's good about is that when
when I go home or I don't see myself as
someone important I'm just a normal guy
I hopefully and people will see me see
me for that I tried to do normal things
I don't do anything different to the guy
in the street I go for a pint I go for
somebody to eat and sometimes I have too
much to drink and but I think that's
what you have to do just to try and be
as normal as possible so that's the way
my kids see me I think for me growing up
oh yeah thank you yes because you got
cracking role model like actually for
myself like bucket he's a Geordie blog
he's doing great himself it's possible
do
I mean and I never set out to be a role
model or never that wasn't a conscious I
just tried to do things right I was
brought the right way I think may not
instilled in you me dad my mom and dad
worked their ass off to to give us me my
sister everything we had my dad worked
in a factory from from 8 o'clock till 5
o'clock every single day and I think
that was that was instilled in me as in
hard work beyond time respect so that's
all I try to do and if that I just I
don't know people say that has been a
role model and then that's fine that's
great but I just try to be as normal as
possible I think there's something about
watching a parent who obviously loved
struggle a bit it's hard to forget that
but when you get success yourself you
saw it it keeps you grounded that memory
alone of don't get to above your station
well I would be the first person to tell
me it would be my dad if I ever did that
I mean even still now to this day my mom
still drops me dad off at the pub picks
him up from the pub he's dinner's ready
when he when he when he comes in from
the pub as it was ready all the time
when he finished work it hit 5 o'clock
so that's the way I was brought up and
that's who I am
like one thing I realized when I started
getting popular myself in Newcastle is
there's it's great because everyone
especially if you're in football people
love you and everyone wants to fall with
you and I'm doing the era's probably
last year but I'm quite well-known these
days
and everyone has a Alan Shearer moment
like if you spot him in the street or
like you're the player everyone talks
about it I started thinking what I knew
this was commonly it couldn't have been
easy all the time because one thing I
realized is people have something like
something like their son he thinks he's
this and you know like because some
people don't like to see people do more
for themselves even if they are from the
same area as young was it ever quite
difficult at times being you cast a so
football focused and you were gone
I had the best job in the world if you
can call a job I just had it how to play
a football if I didn't get paid for it
so to play football and be off decent I
didn't be recognized I hear all the
stories from my hip someone say well he
didn't do this or he didn't do that but
you know what rumors are like him in
Newcastle it's are you aware of it or
like when you walk into a shop or
whatever like the whole room goes like
it is like that I sure must be now
you're aware of it and you can see it's
it's it's quite funny really when you
walk past someone you can see some
there's someone tapping someone your
watcher and book I suppose you get you
get used to that it's the greatest job
in the world to get peered to play
football
mmm as I said I would I would have
played football if I if I got anything
I'd have done on a satirist on there
with me mitts or to be paid for it and
peered probably well for it is is the
best job on the world it doesn't get any
better than that so there's not there's
no way you can ever mourn about being it
a professional footballer the time to
moan is afterwards when you your knees
are not getting their handles and your
back and everything else and that's the
side that people perhaps don't see is
that for for 20 years your true an in
every single deer you have an injections
in your ankle all you need to get out
and play but what always comes back to
you as well so you should do cuz you're
on that much money but you would still
do if I wasn't get any money but then
afterwards when you when you get to 36
or 47 like I am now and your knees are
knackered and your ankles and and you
struggle to to walk opportunities and
quite a lot these days yeah yeah yeah my
yeah my knees are shot I can't I can't
go running on concrete or anything like
that because my knees and ankles and
backing and everything else or are all
seized up so yeah that's the side that
people don't see so now you're a pond it
I kind of thought like being the
Newcastle player and scoring many balls
you did no one could ever complain
I disagree because you always deliver
but upon dit everyone's got an opinion
and everyone can disagree and I know for
a few years I think now people see or
you're one of the best there is
but early on you know a lot of statement
now I got that I understood that and
probably rightly saw because I always
thought I was going to go into
management I was pretty certain I was
going into into management and I was
always reluctant to see how it was and
B's is is upfront and career legal as I
should have been because well because I
thought if I'm going back into football
into management and I'm then I'm
criticized and left right and center on
the TV then I go into management and you
can look a bit of an idiot so I was what
I always held back but then once the
decision was made that the the
management thing wasn't going to happen
then a knuckle down worked hard took
advice and then started to get stuck
into it and graft at it and um even I
don't mind saying now I think I'm a
little bit better now than I was and
when I first started so yeah it takes
time it's it's pretty daunting although
you've played in front of 70,000 with
England and 52,000 every week with
Newcastle and won the Premier League and
then you sit in on live TV knowing that
you can't make a mistake you can't swear
because when you're out in the pub
readmit or on the golf course whatever
you'll you'll see or whatever and then
but you can't do that on live TV once
and that's it you're finished so it's
pretty nerve-wracking to begin with on
live TV but of course you that's you get
the adrenaline rush
whenever you whatever happens when you
finish football and that's probably why
so many players get into trouble when
they retire because I think they got
[__] chasing the drug chasing the
adrenaline rush as in score and all
walking out in the stadium or winning a
game and the one thing you as a
footballer you have to understand is
you're never getting that isn't whatever
you do in your life you're never getting
a big
buzzes as you get on a football pitch
ever again and the one good thing about
live TV is it gives you that adrenaline
rush not as much but it gives you
something and I've been very fortunate
to go from playing football to be paired
they're now talking about football to be
paired so I'm one other lucky guy
where's iconic isn't it that I'm in the
the view and figures but for much of the
deal are just brilliant I mean in the
millions you're talking five or six
million over over a weekend that watches
that program I watched as a kid couldn't
wear fur as a kid my dad watched it
my son's exactly the same now with
probably turns off when I'm on it for
them he's the same now with that with
much today so it's such an iconic
program that it is the best what's it
like working with right Liam that I got
particularly because they cry oh yeah
right he's right he's as mad as as
everyone thinks he is probably a little
bit more the days are a lot shorter with
rightly in the studio then then with
anyone else cuz it's just you just
taking the piss all doing really you
just having a laugh and a joke and in
the meantime trying to watch a little
bit of football added on because you
when you come to do the show you have so
much knowledge and information about the
games how do you manage to get that
throughout the days you get help and
stuff like that are no you've got to do
your own research you've got to you've
got to know what you're talking about
it's a typical day for much the days I
leave New Castle at about 8:30 Saturday
morning get down to Manchester it's a
media city in Salford about half 11
watch the first game coming it at half
12 take your notes and and sit with the
analysts guys
what's the games coming in at 3 o'clock
what's the other game do the see him
take not give it to the guys see him
again at half five and then we go into
the into the Edit and suite it in about
8 o'clock for an hour or so we're in the
editing suite talking through all our
notes what we've given during the day
and what we're gonna do on every game
your lines your dots your circles what
you what you intend to do each other
that what you what you're going to say
do you ever run through that with each
other - I'll say this and then you can
say that not necessarily no it's that's
more adlib and you in the shorten and
then we'll finish it finish that at
about half nine ten o'clock and then go
on live at a half ten and finish at
midnight back in a car back to Newcastle
home at about three o'clock in the
morning but I think the big thing is is
a lot of what a lot of people say to me
is what its life people think we
recorded six or seven o'clock well it's
it's a live program deals out a half ten
finishes at midnight yet that shows it's
a good thing that people don't realize
it's life because it's that well not
make mistakes any attempts you how many
afters would like the last ticket
because I've seen you disagree with
people before and you famously should
show me in China stone people host about
it afterwards like you could have no not
really because that's your chance I mean
that's that's what they won the TV there
is people to have a disagreement to have
a discussion on that particular topic
whatever you're talking about you can
give your opinion I can give mine it's
it's you don't have to always agree in
fact that's what I said they want they
want people to disagree so the more shot
you have other more disagreements you
have the better TV is what you'll notice
like so what are you making note
something you predominantly looking at
the striking no you got a look at me
tsunamis
it's it's very difficult looking when
you've been doing it for 11 years has
I've been doing it now to do something
different every Saturday on it on a
different team so you've always got to
try and find a different angle to what
someone else is looking at whether it's
defending whether it's set pieces or
going forward or the midfielders I think
you've always you always got to try and
find something something different to
talk about because you can't keep coming
out with the same stuff every Saturday
night yeah
yeah but then it's also quite
interesting so obviously we've had
people like Dan Hardy is a UFC fighter
on the show and he said when he became
analyst his view of fighting his
knowledge got so much better
mhm do you think you're originally as a
pundit watching from a strikers
perspective and then over time you've
expanded your view how have you seen
your any illusion no I think that's
that's that's the easy side for me
because if I don't know what I'm talking
about with strikers then I shouldn't
really be on the body on that be on the
program that's the easy part looking at
the center forwards what runs they
should or shouldn't be making or where
they should be and when a cross comes in
or the holdup player that touch whatever
that's that's the easy side of it is
when you start analyzing defending or a
very difficult goal keeping because I've
never been in that position or different
systems then it becomes a little bit
more difficult than you've got to
looking I've got to look into it a
little bit more but regarding the
strikers bit that's that's pretty
natural to me and it should be because
it's obviously different for every
striker so you'll you'll see runs that
maybe another striker wouldn't want to
make mean you know Jermaine if I was
gonna make different runs to you do you
ever see yourself thinking I wish you is
doing that I think wait no that's not
punditry that's amazing yeah yeah that's
but then they don't you don't mind that
you don't mind saying well this is what
I would have done yeah these very
different and I think it's you've what
you've always got to try and do is
you've got to try because we can all sit
back and watch TV and watch a match at
the end and everyone can see it we've
got what we've got to try and do is just
try and tell the viewer something that
they can't see nothing different and
then then you go okay well yeah I get
why you see no I didn't see that or and
that's what we've got to try and do
every Saturday analysis is quite
different know when you I mean it wasn't
wasn't all that long as it was
you know hundred years in great didn't
have the the Saints and all of that I
may have two brain cells to rub together
is that if you if you do you know back
in the day were very much little well
you had a lovely game didn't he and a
lovely game for yes it was a lovely game
did you ever feel the people unfairly
criticized you as a striker or yeah it
never bothered me
no never bothered me one good and I
didn't give a [__] what what people said
because I knew whether I had a poor game
or not I didn't anyone I didn't need
anyone to tell me and and if they did
say I was corrupt then you got to admit
and say well okay I was yeah that's
that's that's part and parcel of
football and there's more because of
social media because there's more TV
programs than ever with with matches on
or highlights on nowadays then if you
can't handle criticism then you're never
ever going to be make it as a footballer
yeah particularly how it is is that it's
it's it's out there for everyone to see
on so many different channels and you've
just got to accept it criticism you know
you can't please everyone and and
certainly when you're trying to talk to
different funds
it's forgive the pun but it's black or
white in it yes either that they're the
biggest fans ever it's their club it's
it's either their players their manager
and if you say anything against their
club then a good comeback it's just
that's life obviously you grow up as a
massive fan there's a lot of dead when
you were growing up well I was not
different my here always was Kevin
Keegan I stood on the went to watch his
debut it it's in James's Park stood it
queued up from 9 o'clock in the morning
was on the Gallagher and watching him
when he scored
got thrown forward like everyone else
and lost all my mates in the crowd who
had gone with
twelve-year-old I think it was 11 or 12
and it was one of my first games so
Keegan was was my hero
I used to stand outside my school it's
gospel sent along the main road there
and we knew what time he was gonna come
past in his car he come back in his jag
when we were all stood at the top of the
school win from the gore bodies to give
us a wave and so I understand how how it
works do you not mean as cuz I've been
there as a kid I had my heroes I wish to
follow him so I get it now that that
when people say to me how much you mean
to the to the young kids I understand it
no like like I don't think many men in
Newcastle would let you sleep it's
mental like what I don't think people
have sighted Newcastle to engage also
have Terry honoree money nated hard
Beckham and Ronaldo whatever but and you
were a diamond the play love [__] and
then you ours as well you were one of us
saw dia and because you didn't leave us
even though we couldn't get like it was
like a husband staying with the wife
even though we didn't have sex with you
Jimmy like you stayed regardless and
that is like people don't forget that
like well it was it was my football club
and I was it was him I grew as soon as I
could walk basically a ball was chucked
at me and a black and white top was was
basically put on me so you have no
choice as the same grow up and Liverpool
I'm pretty sure cuz I lived in Liverpool
for four years and it's very similar to
to what Newcastle is the people and I
had a choice to come back home and I
wanted to play for my club and if you
give me the same decision to make
tomorrow at this image and I would do
exactly see him because for what I've
got in Newcastle what I've achieved the
foundation I it was my dream it wasn't
as if I was signing for a club that was
playing relegation football it was a
club that would just lost I don't know
12 point leader water as the year before
I'm in 95 96 season so
I was going to a club that was
challenging yeah but for whatever reason
it didn't it didn't happen but for me to
wear the number 9 shirt for me to break
Jacky Milburn's record Jackie Milburn
was my dad's hero and so for me to go
back to my area and in front of my
parents brick my dad's Heroes record and
so what he means to so many people in
Newcastle then I will do I would make
exactly same decision tomorrow in fact
if I had to believe that because I know
I would have done the same if I was you
but just going back upon degree I was
wondering is there only ponder that you
watch across all the channels that you
think he's my sort of favorite football
at what point did you realize you know
I'm pretty good at football I thought I
was pretty good then and then I got the
offer to go down to Southampton as a 13
year old was Jackie there was an old
fella called who sadly is no longer with
us
and passed away a few years ago he went
and asked my parents after it was how
the City game or a boys club glim game I
like the lobby is son I would like to
invite them to down to Southampton for a
trial and typical of why my parents said
well why you asking us for gone ask him
so he did and then myself and six or
seven of us went down to south on for a
trial in one of the school holidays and
I loved it it was brilliant but then
when I got down there because I was
probably the best in my school maybe the
best at the boys club when I got down
there then everyone from around the
country came together and I thought I'm
not as good as I thought was here and
sort had to step up a bit science school
board forms for South omlette 14 which
he could do then and 14 to to 16 and
then was um
was on the brink and I remember there
was a game that we had one of the last
games down in south um as a 15 year old
ass called hatrick and they're very one
of the very last game which I think made
the decision for Southampton to ask me
to sign as an apprentice which meant out
to leave home at 15 and go on live in
Southampton on my own that was probably
the one of the best decisions I ever
made in my career got away from
everything being done for me got away
from some of my mates who were Romans
had to grow up had to live on my own
how old I was in digs 15 yeah helped me
sort of be the way I was and and I
remember pulling away out of the station
central station and my mom and dad stand
on the platform wave and I can see my
mum getting upset and I'm thinking geez
am i doing the right thing here but it
was it was one of the best decisions I
ever made because it wasn't as if I
could come home every weekend because we
couldn't afford the train fare when we
were only on 25 quid a week on a whitey
s key we got a bus pass but I didn't
used to get the the past I used to go
and collect the money because I only
lived off a mile from the del as it
wasn't in South I'm sorry I had to walk
so that was an extra few quid for me but
I couldn't jump on the tree and on the
car whatever and come on because I was I
was homesick so I had to grow up and
grow up pretty fast and it worked for me
it was a good decision well lift him I
lived on my own and with another family
to begin with for about a year and then
another guy from Darlington Neil Madison
he came to live in and digs with me as
well and we had such we had we had a
great laugh it was it was brilliant as I
said we only lived off on my over on the
corner from the ground so we still walk
in the mornings but those were the days
and the apprenticeships where you have
to clean the toilets the stands the
boots you weren't allowed in the
first-team dressing room until you
actually are you either clean in there
or you were in there because you're
playing
and that gave us a great it's a great
incentive for us to try and get in there
and and they did things right itself
happening with their record over the
years long before me that their record
of bringing kids through even now is
magnificent do you think Newcastle in
Southampton helped you technically as a
footballer as well yeah definitely
well don't because we had my manager
down there at the time was a guy called
Chris Nichol he gave me my year he gave
you my my debut at 17 we used to work so
so hard and guy in the youth team was
Dave Manson he was a UC manager true and
every single day morning afternoon and
that was that was the life that I wanted
that was the life that I saw for myself
till we honest I haven't got a clue what
I would have done if I hadn't have been
a football I just put all my eggs in the
one basket basket and hoped and prayed
that I'd be a footballer thankfully at
work you have that mentality of one egg
one basket and I'm gonna obsess over
this yeah would you say well quite
obsessive at that time it was the only
thing I ever did it was I didn't like
school I only went to school because of
my mates
I had a great attendance record that was
the only good thing about my about my
school report was my attendance record
and probably because of that was put in
from him from my dad hasn't been on time
personally did I mean when I was poorly
all my mum and dad used to kick me on
the bed and said get yourself in school
so that yeah it was that was that was
why I definitely I was obsessed with its
finished school go out and play football
till it was dark and then used to get
dragged into the house and the next day
that CMD was every day you know he said
I saw them didn't you like clean the
boots on the toilet so everything what
is it like for a 16 there Rouladen like
the Newcastle
thing now where now is that they're
totally different it's really different
yeah they have they have they have guys
who clean the boots have guys who do the
dressing rooms they're not allowed to do
that now that was under the old whitey s
scheme which i think is a great shame
you know because although it was pretty
shitty at the time and horrible it
didn't off teach you a little bit of
respect
yeah absolutely and looking back when
you get to 24 25 you look by anything
that was actually good for merely age
because absolutely my first job I was
working to butcher I was cleaning like
like phrase doesn't something blood off
the wall but like now I'm so grateful
enough to do I'd be but it's currently
building yeah whereas now it just feel
like a lot of young footballers have got
an entitled attitude if there's one if
there was one thing I could change about
football it would be that it would be
just to start that all over again to get
the kids to do all the jobs clean the
boots etc but they're not allowed to do
it now I think the government is stopped
in there probably on so much money I was
60 and as well that their agents
wouldn't allow them and not that I think
nice problems one of the problems of
part and parcel while were perhaps not
bringing up bringing up kids and threw
the football through the ranks as many
as we should be it is interesting
because they say also in certain
football clubs now they they want to
take their youngsters to places that
they think aren't as privileged and make
the players play those players so they
feel what it's like to be and they have
to make their own way there and those
sorts of things and the probably the
players and just get loved like people
can't make there are there it's so
bizarre so much to Sooners but I mean
you've got you gotta have something to
strive for you've got to be hungry and
eager and keen and and and want to do
everything you can to get to a certain
point whereas a lot of the players
nowadays have too much money too young
there's no incentive there for them to
lay you the millionaire's already by the
time the 80 and then where did they go
from one yeah well you always if you're
in the footballing world as a young kid
yours you particularly if you're a
Premier League club then you're always
gonna have more than your mates
yeah but then that's fine but then
there comes a time where you've got to
keep the hunger and the drive and the
desire where as if if already you've got
stacks and stacks of money at 18 and 19
then where'd you get your drive from and
you and your desire and your hunger take
all that extra desolation isn't there
like that I have to succeed is this like
Theo Walcott for me is a classic example
of someone who literally happen when
he's thrown adieu from being 1617 and
you could argue hasn't delivered anyone
you know what you could have done money
was promises than you thierry ordinary
and that's I mean yes it's difficult to
say where he could have gone I
personally had an excuse you know two
failures not the best a lot but just
saying like maybe if you said until he
18 years old you can't earn any more of
that like not salary covered permanently
but 285 something salary cap in sports
isn't all unless it's it's a put in a
trust
yeah the FEL the PFA or whether can put
it into a trust so you can get it at it
at a later date when you're a little bit
more responsible D and so at what point
do you think because you say you didn't
you you realize you may be workers I'm
you know the the best player in the
Academy
what point did you begin to pull away
and become the island share that I never
thought I was ever the best and that's
what kept me going
I always wanted to get there and I
wasn't the best even unless I was
looking off I scored a hat-trick on my
dear B was 17 for Southampton against
Arsenal and the next day the next Sunday
morning the manager Chris nickel had me
and clean the boots clean the dressing
room Hoover and um the toilets here but
Don let me say lucky to score a
hat-trick got three goals well you
always water in whatever worker life you
need you need a little bit of look yeah
but I wasn't the best technically at
that eh I but what I was the best at was
working out hmm
I'm being on time and given everything
and that's why I got to where I did is
that I was determined I was hungry and I
worked my ass off to get where I work
whereas some players might have been
happy with what they achieved then I
wanted to get better and better and
better and I wasn't I wasn't the best at
17 18 19 but what I lacked in in a touch
or heading or shooting or whatever then
I was determined to work hard to make
myself and I'll remember dear merits in
my youth coaches Southampton seemed to
me throughout your career you're gonna
hear someone say idiot you've got to
work on your left foot and you should
say to me you make sure your right foots
unstoppable so when they're trying to
put you onto your left foot still go on
your right and make your right foot
deadly and I always remember that and I
worked and I worked and I worked in the
worked a little bit more to make my
right foot as it was and it was great
advice hmm as are some of the best
advice you've had you think yeah but
certainly in my younger days it it's
South Hampton yeah I was able to tick
everything in a listen but the most
important thing is his hard work and
Grafton wanting to do it wanted to get
up when it's pissing down the rain in
the morning or wanted to steer behind
when everyone's gone on or and that's
that's probably how I was able to
advance a little bit more than others
because I was prepared to work hard and
go the extra mile it's it's funny
because adult I was thinking how that
feels a young kid to be a 17 year old
making your debut for a team like
Southampton hmm do you remember what
that was like that laughing - I didn't I
didn't I was in the squad I didn't find
out I was playing until midday right on
the Saturday Danny Wallace at the time
was at South um field a fitness test
Saturday morning and then Chris nickel
came to me it's I don't know half eleven
twelve o'clock said you're in your plane
and of course my parents didn't have
time to get from Newcastle to
Southampton so I was I was basically on
my own and I remember going to the hotel
having pretty much meal and my first
pretty much meal was Phil its dick the
guy came along what he wanted and I said
it Phil it's dig and they all looked at
me the only reason I said it was because
I've never had it before anyway so yeah
that was my first ever pretty much meal
because it's too expensive to restaurant
if the club spirit from also were the
defending champions thought seasons well
also we're a decent team then yes so
awesome so yeah it was it was a great
day I mean to score
Patrick him I made it hard for myself in
one word because everyone expected that
week in week out I never scored again
after that game that season Wow I
wouldn't say that was April so I went
all the way till the year to the middle
of back end of me and never scored
another goal I feel the pressure after
that yeah I felt it was difficult yeah
and because everyone was looking at me
everyone knew who I was albeit son was a
relatively small area come when you look
at the the Football Club but it was
difficult found the next season tough as
well didn't score a lot of goals then
the same thing happened a hurricane a
little bit like the heat so I didn't hit
the ground running straight away well
he's had to do it the hard way that's
one of the things that that I like about
him I said he's had nothing on a place
not nothing's been given to him easy he
has had to work for everything he's have
to go out on Lorne he's a - he hasn't he
hasn't there you are there's your first
team you're gonna play every single week
he's up to go on graft and work and I
didn't work from a beginner if I only
just worked for him
last was it three years three and a half
years now so but the successes ever now
deserves it because he's had to go out
and graft on one that's interesting is
actually a party no it's given him the
opportunity absolutely party no doesn't
loan out young players that he thinks I
promised did you have anyone like that
who had a particular faith in you well
and then after the season after that
that was my first the season that I had
with Southampton 91-92 was the first
season that was a regular goalscorer
I've got into the into the 20s for rare
for South um I was playing England
under-21s Andrea Harford who was the
coach at the time at Blackburn was the
England under-21 coach and manager so he
knew what who I was what I was about and
then that's when Blackburn came in for
me in that summer of of 1992 just after
I made my debut I made my debut for
England February 92 and then left that
that someone you had other office yeah I
had a few offers I got a call from Kenny
Douglas at Blackburn and he was Jack
Walker real Harford under-21s and of
course Kenny I went to meet them and it
was they were brilliant Kenny they had
great plans and Jack was a very wealthy
guy very successful businessman he was
the owner of Blackburn and I've just
thought with Kenny with ray and with
Jack that it was gonna be pretty
powerful at Blackburn and I went to meet
them on the Monday or Tuesday and I
think they told me everything I wanted
to hear and I said give me three or four
days I'll give you an answer by the by
the end of the week
and then I got a call from from
representative Manchester United saying
that we're interested in you said well
have promised to give Blackburn an
answer by the end of the week I would
love to come and talk to you and they
said well because I think they were PLC
they had to go and borrow the money I
said well if you want without watch then
you'll you'll get the money somehow and
then you'll make a decision on me and I
never heard anything back from them so
I'll give the answer to Blackburn er yes
and then I went to some British record
as well wasn't it
there is British record transfer fee
yeah I think it was 3.6 million I think
something like oh man how did that feel
having so much because that is the first
point of your life I guess we've heard
that came two figures involving you yeah
and now the pressure is really on and
also knowing that it's Kenny dog leash
that said spend 3.6 million because we
know can you double each now as an older
state an elder statesman the game sorry
yes I know my mind can actually follow
me sorry so we know the Kennedys doesn't
elder stating the game now and you know
we've seen his second time a little
called this generation would have seen
that but at that time that was Kenny dog
leash best player in the world at one
point though one of the best managers in
the world haven't played champagne
football and he's coming to you having
managed in Russia all the time the same
a line I loved it I thought I thought
while with someone stupid enough to peer
that then that's their problem
I am I love the I enjoyed it I mean I
hear people talk about the pressure of
the world's most expensive fee or
Britain's most expensive player but I
loved it I thought if if Wow someone's
prepared to pay that money for me little
allow from Newcastle who just work hard
and try sod and scores the odd that's
the utmost faith cause it's put in your
mouth it's brilliant and ya know it was
I enjoyed that pressure is it not really
pressure as it's it's gone back to being
peered for something you you love doing
okay so you see isn't it like because
some people would say that is intense
pressure other people usually say
pressures retires in it that's all
that's right that's what I used to to
see and then again the same thing
happened it went wild was leaving
Blackburn and the world's most expensive
player go on for for 15 million quid and
I just thought wow
I'm the world's most expensive
footballer nice to kick a ball around in
Park Avenue and Gosforth yeah really
this is in Blackpool you hit the ground
running you're smashing them in but you
got your first big injury in Blackburn
what people do forget when they compare
you to win Rooney is after the main
people being really cited 16 in the
Premier League you like well like 21 I'd
yeah I'd like three major injuries yeah
what was it like from a but from that
ACL
well I'd it was I was devastated because
I had such a great start to life at
Blackburn I'm out scoring goals for fun
I think I had 22 goals signed in the
middle of August and then I did my
cruciate ACL on Boxing Day about twenty
two girls from August 2 to Boxing Day
and then that's it bang I'm out for the
next seven or eight months so on
cruciate ligament I try to first of all
they diagnosed it with it was a college
problem and it wasn't too serious I
tried to come back and I came back in a
game for 20 minutes and money collapsed
and then that was it
I always remember the day because I went
down with it with the with the physio at
that time Paul Ferris and the two of us
and we had the operation on February the
14th Valentine's Day and mean my mate
the physio Paul Ferris are in this
hotels and
together yeah I'm going in for operation
the next day and I said I've got half a
couple of beers before any word for
operation it's always start together in
a bar and that's why I always remember
that that deer and then from February
they I was out for about seven months so
it was tough it was really tough because
I said things were great but I had a
great medical team if the surgeon was
was a great guy down in Cambridge called
dr. David Dundee and I remember because
they were struggling to find out what
the injury was because it would been
four or five weeks for it to get the
diagnosis and it's just guy this surgeon
and I remember walking in and barely my
trousers would all be at the ground and
he saw said you've ruptured your ACL
you're gonna be able for six or seven
months don't worry he'll be as good as
new by the time we get your back it'll
be a successful operation and I was
meant to be in hospital for two days and
then just as I believe the hospital in
Cambridge after the operation felt I
felt terrible I got an infection in my
leg so I was in the hospital for two
weeks so it wasn't easy it wasn't easy
start of rehabilitation but I got there
worked odd and then the question was was
he gonna be as good as he was before the
injury and then the more people asked
then it was like okay great keep asking
and then that sauce bird beyond two to
do that I was young enough all sorted I
didn't really lose any peace because of
because of that injury was only in the
latter stages that were the series
hinged up and began to lose a yard
appears but after that I just I felt
great and it was Kenny he was brilliant
at that time because I was itching to
get back in the in the team and after it
was I thought I was ready come the end
of August but he kept putting me back
and put me on his sub for ten minutes
for half an hour and then he um my first
callback was ironically at since James's
part when I came on as a sub for
Blackburn
against Newcastle and then scored
I got hammered off all my mates we were
in the kissing end you come out with you
can see the ball yeah that was it I was
back to scoring goals again it was fine
than that and I've never had a problem
with that knee to that to this day hmm
so that Bluff a team of people nowadays
think of Leicester was the ultimate
underdogs but that Blackburn team at the
end was the ultimate underdogs of the
era money corner yeah yeah like real
characters like Colin Hendry and like
he's iconic in life we had a we had a
brilliant team spirit in that in that
that squad Tim Sherwood
Colin Henry Tim flowers David batty
Wilcox Rick Lee was a system designed
for a center for to score goals to to
great wing as in whip Ripley and Wilcox
and all that they were ever told to do
was get bought in the box and that was
just music to my ears
and it was a great system to play and it
was it was just designed to score goals
and for Blackburn to come in to the
Premier League like they did and take on
the big boys of arsenal liverpool money
and I had Chelsea Ollie's and beat them
and beat them to the Premier League the
difference between Blackburn and
Lester's that everyone knew we were
coming Blackburn there was we'd spent
money but like Mannion I did like
Liverpool like all the bigger clubs they
all spend money together and and they're
not as criticised as much as Blackburn
were then and I said well Blackburn
bought the title well who doesn't
yeah and the difference between
Leicester and Blackburn I think was
everyone knew we were coming no one saw
Lester coming at all unless they just
got on a roll at the beginning of the
season and it was like a snowball effect
norm would stop them once they started
it was it was just incredible so and I
think that was the the difference but
for clubs why's this statue um yeah
probably the same size and it was it was
a miracle as well and obviously I can
lead a village which means a lot of
people are looking at you because he was
very keen he had already been successful
Liverpool as his manager I think you've
done the double as manager it
it Liverpool and he was brewing this
great guy still is to this day
entomology ology because you know this
is somewhat ugly girls for my mom on
each other he was he never he never did
know he very rarely did any Cochin he
was a manager he had real Harford to do
all of his to do all of his coaching and
what rear was brilliant and coaching he
was a genius at that but then of course
we won the league and then Kenny left
can he went into the director of
football role
where was that sort of changed things at
Blackburn because then real Harford took
over Kenny I'm the big mistake that
really made us is that we didn't sign
any players when we won the lead he
thought it was with him being as honest
as he is he thought he would give that
team the chance to do that all again
whereas the mystery of what you have to
do is is you have to sign you have to
get bigger and better and then the
dominoes over the trainer promise was
there was talk of Zidane and Christophe
do GUI
come and sign in for rare for Blackburn
booked um I'm not even sure he got as
far as a training ground to be honest
that he might he got into Blackburn and
turned around we got it was a
disappointing season and because of that
was one of the reasons that we didn't
sign in and I think we finished fifth or
six or something like that then that was
the time for me to to think about moving
because other clubs were started to
circulate in coming from was it like the
finally win the Premier League title or
well we know you threw it away then we
lost at the under I mean we were we've
sat at the top of the league and United
were chestnuts and Fergie was putting
the pressure on us as he as he as he
always used to do and then we went to
Anfield
they needed the way man you know you
needed to win at West Ham and we all I
think we needed just a point to win the
league and of course I think when one
nil up I scored and then we were we were
[__] ourselves bitter we were really
nervous
and you could tell despite going one in
Liverpool got one back and then they
scored to go to one open I'm you know
I'm thinking Tim flowers I've seen
interview how many I thought as soon as
it when one one we've done it we're
finished looking wrong you know cuz
they're real weird atmosphere because
we're in an field and even the Liverpool
players don't want money now in the Lea
and they know if they beat us they're
given a great chance to mine United who
at west arm to win the league but and
then all of a sudden we just see all the
Blackburn funds gone mad and I see Kenny
Andrea Hogan on the touchline and I
thought thank God for that we've we've
worn it you know you'd haven't haven't
been West Ham and the title was a so we
had a hell of a few years I know that
you were quite I up heard a lot of
interesting stories about you as a squad
quite mischievious maybe is the way I've
heard a hammer story on the coach I
don't know that was ridiculous I wasn't
part of it I was on the table cost of
course yeah we had there it was David
Botti Tim Sherwood Mike Neil I think
who's Tim flowers were the other one is
that the other little hammers to break
the windows in case of emergency yeah
well there's someone's bright idea at
the back of the bus to tap the window
but every player had to tap it a little
bit harder now no child is stupid and
then of course were gone along the
waterway one day on the way that we came
and it's getting harder and harder and
I'm looking back at the guys then all of
a sudden the course of wind or smash
and to this day I think the lads will
know the lads of what was said that
Kenny they're all as if as if they're
shocked goodness could you put the
hammer back into where it to where it
was and can't even you know and Kenny
thought it was a chip and they had
cracked him we were just going along the
motorway nicely yeah yeah stupid on them
what was that that was quite a dressing
room to be part of those it was great
yeah we heard that's what so what got us
through in the end was a team spirit I
mean when you when you can't compare
some other players that we had in our
team to the to the likes it man United
or Chelsea or whatever then it was an
incredible achievement and that's what
got us through in the end team spirit
and hard work so they end up going back
the Newcastle that was after year on 86
now for me I've sort of gotten into
football about a year before year in 86
so I'll say
and it's been Newcastle funds and then
your latest on something he's me fail
play out here selling ironies from me
what's ailing them yeah fantastic
what was the limping in the Politburo 96
because that for me was the best thing
than team I've ever seen yeah it was say
it was brilliant
to to be part of but it was difficult in
a way leading up to it because all our
scoring goals were fun still for
Blackburn I hadn't scored for England
for nearly two years I think it was i
think is about 12 games and so there was
so many calls for me to be left out with
that team Euro 96 Bala strikers were
doing well like less firmly foul
Collymore
mullet is a David Hurst and he call
Chris Sutton so they had all these guys
who were scoring goals who were putting
pressure on me and I hadn't scored for
England but what what happened was is
that we went on it on the move from his
trip to China and Hong Kong other one
the newspaper where I think is like as I
remember I was in there but I was too
clever because I've seen people take
pitches and that's local offer on the
back Terry Venables before we went to
China and Hong Kong we had through three
games and pre Euro 96 friendly games and
he said to me whatever happens in
between now and the tournament start you
will be my number one centre forward you
will start the first game and I thought
wow for the manager to have that much
faith in me and put that much trust in
me I've got to repair this guy and he
said once you start then the rest is up
to you and then we did what we did in
Hong Kong and China with a dentist's
chair and everything else and we got
hammered from pages back pages and
deservedly so we had to perform whose
idea was that
is there anyone it was the instigator
dentist chair and just Cornell again but
yeah it was just it was a team thing as
that we will we all said when we were
out late we had we had a curfew I think
it was about midnight or 1 o'clock in
the morning and everyone sort of looked
at each other and thought well if one
goes back we all have to go if we all
stay then the manager can't really do
anything so it was that sort of
mentality yeah we let the manager down
and gambled a bit in the gamble
backfired and of course the ripped
shirts were all over the front pages of
the newspapers and it was it was madness
and then that sort of pulled us together
as a squad because we got battered
and rightly saw but we stuck together we
gelled as a tea succeed mentally it was
yes battery needs in the press
the other way the press will hammer on
us and rightly saw and that's what
helped us in a way because we went into
the first game it wasn't a great result
luckily I scored in the first game
Switzerland
we got draw and then it was just
gathering momentum great atmosphere then
would be Scotland it was one of those
thing that tournament thought like
football's coming home yeah it was great
fun early success that Wembley and all
that it was I don't know I don't think
any tournament ever felt the same since
we weren't aware of the of the
atmosphere really because we were locked
away in the hotel in our hotel in in
Burnham beeches it was and it wasn't
until one afternoon where we had the
afternoon off and Terry Venables said it
was just go out for a walk out of the
hotel and we went out of the hotel and
walked into little little bit Burnham
and it was just madness this little
village it was there was thousands of
people out there and we couldn't go
anywhere and we thought wow the
country's kicking off it's brilliant and
then of course that's when we got a real
feel for that there's something good
something special going on here in 96
and then that Holland game when that was
probably the best atmosphere that I've
ever played in and to beat Holland for
was it was an incredible game I got to
Teddy got to I think as well and it was
just incredible - brilliant when I look
back at that team I think what what's
different from that team to a lot of
other England teams was there were so
many leaders yeah and it fell like you
can really rely on so many of these
blocks to come in and put a decent
performance and and not be afraid to
tell someone what's going wrong and what
should be doing yeah I think that that
that when you look at the England team
now - the England team then in 96 I
think that's that probably the big
difference and one of the big
differences is that there's so many
captains and their 96 team myself
Teddy Tony Adams Gareth Southgate David
Seaman Pauline's Gary Neville
I've probably forgot two or three there
was a lot of people who saw Universal
those guys were pretty and David Platt
yeah I was at the same and was like a
seasoned pro as well yeah that's right
so it was there was a lot of leaders in
that team lot of captains for that
team's also meet David Beckham isn't
getting bit coupling in that side left
me on Jeremy
great he's great team spirit it was
great it was a great month it was just
incredible yeah in the court book you
know what happened penile reason that's
one of those things are those things you
got the golden book so I got the Golden
Boot I remember because we got knocked
out so obviously in the semi-final
against against Germany and Germany were
in the final um and I think it was
number Center for most sure it was
Klinsmann or not but I was I was sat at
home watching the final thinking because
if their center Ford got two girls you
were beating me to the gold booth
something I don't care if you win just
don't get to a girl to let me get the
golden boot but thankfully it was I got
it yes after not scoring for two years
and twelve games and then to end up
tournament's top scorer was was pretty
special because you still heroes in many
ways I know it was that Gaza call they
got Oh God but I think they left or I
think of you getting the world in that
cool yeah and obviously the same
celebration what was it like playing
with Gaza cuz you know from her often he
was he was a genius as a player
brilliant but got his mud he was an
absolute fruitcake and great fun I mean
a month was enough with him mmm-hmm for
the guys that didn't have to follow his
appendix but ya know lock in a hotel a
month was definitely enough here because
of the practical jokes used to go into
you used to wake up in the morning and
he'd put your pants on he had DP and
your pants and he was like he'd been in
your room and sneaked in your room
before and trashed your room and it was
just he was yeah he was it was it was
great a good fun of the time for a month
was definitely enough spending a month
with Gaza
more talented player in from England no
I don't think so he was he was he was
just brilliant what he could do with
them with a football I was he was
brilliant and of course he's one of the
guys that suffered really from from not
having the boss of the football to going
to train and two matches and Wathan it's
it's a shame to see him in the in their
way is it at times because some people I
guess just aren't cut out to be for the
limelight like you can be given all this
natural talent but mentally you might
not be prepared for whatever else
everything is going to come with it he
did an interview with him recently which
I thought was really great the questions
and he seemed a better version of
themself and he has been in the last few
years but he still he still has his ups
and downs he's as he's good dear such as
he's he's bad dears obviously but he's
genuine and he would give you and that's
part that's been part of his problem
over the years is that he'd give you his
last penny he'd rather you studied
rather someone else have it than him and
that has been an issue for him or over
the over the years but because you're a
footballer because you have so much
money you're expected to handle
everything
well sometimes footballs are normal as
well you know and that that is is an
area where I think football can improve
because a lot of footballers and I mean
a lot of football has come from a
background where that parents have had
no money I've been brought up on council
estates
and they've had nothing else but
football similar to myself born and it
council I was raised in the council
house not a great area and then all of a
sudden because he's good at footballers
16 or 17 and he gets 21 you should be
able to talk in front of millions you
should be to be able to be eloquent in
front of a camera if you're single and
you can't do anything wrong I mean come
on it's nominee is it's not worse or if
I was a footballer
yes we would love them they're too much
popular we were skeptical about just
this quick place where it is looming yes
must what I find quite just about you is
people don't they don't know a lot about
you as a person we said this earlier
good obviously but yeah exactly so
thanks for coming up but you do build up
very close relationships with people
behind the scenes because everyone needs
to be to have told the number of people
who are yet on the show he's a great guy
a great guy
you must have built up great bonds with
people that Gaza and your teammates
behind the scenes because obviously
you're not private but then the orient
quite closer at those times what was
that like having that sort of
brotherhood with what what happens that
I went to when I went to Blackburn Kenny
had the Kenny Douglas had the same sort
of personality as everyone told me what
a great guy he was where you'd see this
guy on the TV or listening to him on
radio deadpan you wouldn't give anything
away so I spent four years with Kenny so
I believe all life no one likes a laugh
and a joke more than I do
no one likes a pint more than I do going
out with your mates going away to play
golf on golfing trips with the lads
you wanna piss with Chris there was a
plot he's mine he's going
really simple years ago I mean I bought
everything I was going through those
facing your plates out that plate in
your face honey wait was someone you
denied over frozen people well he was
when I went I think it was in like Italy
or somewhere all his contacts were in
there in Italy that I knew where he
could take us another one who would find
out where we were in a bar and what have
you
well I went one of my first England
trips was that we used to room together
when when we went away with England then
so in 92 I was so put in the energy
sharing a room with with David platen so
that's how we saw I've got to to know
each other and of course he had a great
career both in England and in Italy and
what was that like being with plaque
would you were you happy to be paired
with him what did you sort of want to be
paid who do you want to be acknowledged
by no we got on we got on fine who was
it was good he was um he obviously
captain England also um we also we also
had shared the same agent and who
basically would we weren't we were
taught not to say anything we wouldn't I
would give our phone numbers I emails
and kept everything very very private so
not was there anything to the press so
that's probably one of the reasons also
okay so after a year in 86 the bidding
war begins
everyone wants on sheera somehow ends up
in Newcastle luckily one of the men who
made that happen was for any Shepherd
who suddenly just passed away yeah he
also was at your statue unveiling and
yeah it's been very friendly over the
years can you tell us what he was like
he was brilliant great guy um honest
hard-working from Newcastle yeah
successful not only as the chairman of
Newcastle United bodies other businesses
also he just loved the era he loved the
Football Club and his passion then
hunger for it for everyone to look at
Newcastle and loved Newcastle and feel a
part of Newcastle and that's that's what
he wanted
that was when I first met him when I was
meeting the Newcastle top brass sir to
have discussions of whether to come back
home or go elsewhere stay at Blackburn
and it felt like there was ambition when
he was at the charge as opposed to now
where it just feels like I mean let's
just hope we don't get relegated it with
him it really felt like even if it
wasn't in his power to me it was win
everything he really wanted to try well
I think the difference is he loved the
Football Club and that you can't say
that at the moment yeah and there was
always it was there was always a marquee
sign in a big sign and most more summers
that they put the neck on the line to
give the the manager at the player that
that he wanted and it wasn't for the
wand of Tryon that that Newcastle didn't
win win a trophy under and when he was
when he was the chairman but he used him
and a few others used all of that
persuasive powers through to get me back
to Newcastle because it was such a big
decision no no it was eight times I was
staying at Blackburn times I was going
to man United and then I got I got a
call off Kevin Keegan to say can I have
another half an hour with you two or
three days later he said I'm I'm coming
down to to Manchester believe or not can
I have another half an hour with you and
I said yes because I was in them in the
stage where I was thinking give me a few
years after think about it and then I
went and met him and then I left my home
to go meet Kevin in Manchester and I
said that's it I'm going I'm signing for
Newcastle and what was it that was so
awful it was just I thought you know
what I was everything that I wanted to
play for Newcastle I wanted to wear the
number 9 shirt I wanted to score goals
it was my dream and I thought what am I
waiting for this is all that prepared to
break the bank that bits a world-record
fee then the guy who you idolized
joy no that's right absolutely yeah and
so I left my home to go and meet Kevin
never ever went back to the house I got
a taxi I got a taxi dude I got my missus
to pack me a bag send it in a taxi to
Manchester Airport got on a flight to
the to the Far East where Newcastle were
in pre-season and then I sign there and
then and I never went back home flew
back into Newcastle
did the press conference and so I left
all the work of back in the house of
Neverland to the family what happened
with Manchester United's cause at that
point because I would say that is a very
difficult named bat away Sir Alex and I
just you know I did that
especially the team I know they had a
great team and I was pretty much
guaranteed trophies which Newcastle he
was my love for the football club I
stood on the terraces as a kid on the
Galaga and cheering Keegan on and and I
wanted people to do that to me and me
going home for that world record fee and
when I did that I went to him saying
that we came back from from the Far East
and they announced that I was gonna sign
on that particular day and have an open
day I've been on money was there fifteen
sixteen seventeen thousand something I
was pouring around it was a midweek day
and I looked out and I walked on I just
saw all these kids and all I think in
Jesus alcohol you know I was school why
aren't you working there was thousands
there live
[Applause]
well you were you because you say you
remember when he signed the magician for
Newcastle United
I remember where I was I was at the
silver link Newcastle to Aden and I walk
past some person who's working in its
offshore wells would be nothing grander
than have you an island Shira saying the
nosing I'm going to get into my major
insight I think it's like Willy Wonka's
chocolate factory headed long-term yeah
you would have gotten the trophies but
you you would have been a great player
in a long line of great players and you
would never have been loved
I mean way to really use that top course
for money I don't exactly love I mean
that's not he's not coming from new cuts
different being like that no that's
right you know it's very easy if you're
not if you're not from particular area
I'm a control and see well if you're
from Liverpool it would have probably
been your dream to have played for
Liverpool
well I was from Newcastle and it was it
was my club it was my dream to to play
for them and to have the girls go on
record to beat Jackie Milburn to have
what half of a Newcastle to have have
played there for 10 years was that was
just it was the best decision what was
Kevin Keegan like because he's a he's a
bit of a figure of funny money before he
left after three or four months yes yeah
me I still don't know the real reason to
be honest it Tim I'm also a business
thing going on at the fella over this
world or for whatever reason finances or
whatever so I sang in the August and
then Kevin left round about the
Christmas time after right after that
you really shot
he comes back your friend I was there
[__] his first game in charge
actually and what really surprised me on
his ear our new customers he let call
for manager NOLA and brought him des
Holden and Stefan give ocean tell me it
was I don't want to succeed with
Keegan's players I want my own players
in there which that makes sense to a
degree I thought it would have thought
it was a great appointment at the time
because obviously with what his success
he had its early success he had at
Blackburn and I thought he was
tailor-made coming into a big club like
like Newcastle Book Night for whatever
reason it didn't work out we should
never saw less we had we had one season
together me and less and we got fourteen
nine goals I think between us I missed
two months through injury he missed
three months I mean imagine like being a
fully fit season you'd been looking at
the Sun well easily did they told him
that they no longer wanted him or gonna
sell him to Tottenham and then I went to
play in the preseason game with
Newcastle in the tournament are Everton
at Goodison Park and broke my ankle
snap where do my ligaments ruptured
whatever displaced the joint so all of a
sudden lifts all as he's free to go
I've ruptured my uncle I'm gonna be out
for six or seven months and but they've
gone back to less and said look this is
what's happened to Alan we've made a
mistake we don't want you to now to
leave for Tottenham can you reverse your
decision and to let his credit said no
you've told me I'm not wanted so Joseph
a really nice blows on a hoodie a grand
fella yeah I did that with less and then
I'm caddied for him last week at the the
British market in the prom he normally
very good but he's hopeless last week
there's a curious cat probably
just in the background don't miss it
honor the good ladies
so what was it like building up a
relationship with him because a lot of
people I mean obviously recently seen
Neymar step out of Messi shadow shadow
and argue with Cavani when he got into
PSG what was he like building
relationships as a strike
there's a strike about things it was
always two up top pretty well you have
to know exactly yeah Sammy when in the
vast majority teams certainly up until
was twenty nine thirty that I was it was
always two up front yeah and that was
the system that everyone saw it played
whether it was main Chris Sutton main
Mike Neal I mean Matt Letizia it's it's
southampton or myself and less at
Newcastle or Beardsley Osprey or Craig
Bellamy whoever it might have been so no
it's fine it's that my job was to score
goals and the good thing about being a
center for is he gonna have an absolute
stinker for 89 minutes and score the
winning goal and beam out of much
whereas if you defender and you give him
a sticky win at least to a goal you've
had a nightmare and that's a good thing
about being a centre forward well it's
also the hardest job they spotting the
ball on the backhand net which is why
their strikers go off a big door and
while they get paired the most and which
is which is why every team in the bottom
half if they had a guy that could put
the ball in the back of the net and get
15 or 20 goals then the the change of
the horses and five or six places of the
year of the league and isn't there's not
many around nor do so
Clemmy takes us from second in the lead
to 13th and he gets moved out yeah
brutal it gets moved in and that was
someone who didn't really see eye to eye
with yeah
Oh Chelsea so what he was yes you care
when everyone got the wigs somebody was
being for a while until we did a photo
shoot with tulips in his pocket reading
weird at the time so when he came in
was it an instant dislike oh yes we just
like each other from the minute the
first way we make Holland you think I
don't know I just you know I just get
feeling when you walked in and he saw
would sort of introduced to each other
and hi hi lovely boy used to call me and
I just I just thought we're not gonna
get on it
lovely boy lovely boy yeah it was it was
just it was do you just got a feeling uh
[__] and he had just and then within
within a week or two
he'd just sort of dismissed all the
senior players yeah me Rob Stewart
Pierce John Barnes Ian Rush Warren bomb
and all those guys were just saw put to
one side it was like It was as if he
didn't want any senior players
challenging I'm taking him on he didn't
want a new origin for him Eagle White's
because if he's try to assert his
dominance but you have put on Eagle no
say the others economy is the problem
it's not like
as a goal scorer the fans love them if
you want to drop him or whatever you
want to create this this is my club take
me that situation then even if you are
good enough that is gonna probably for
someone like a hobbit yeah it said it
was a difficult situation because I knew
that you wanted me all the Football Club
but I didn't want to leave but I would
have had to a left if if you had a
steered boom he he he saw a gamble he
put all his eggs in the one basket
didn't even sort left me out of the
biggest game of the season Sundblom
because I'd been I was suspended for
this game before hunt they were beaten
at home and then I think he kept it the
same team against Sunderland in a
midweek he left you wouldn't have done
them first and no together that's fine
it's a manager you're entitled to leave
whoever you want no you pick that scene
anything's gonna win the game but the
thing is also a way of doing it so to
walk into the dressing room at 6:30 and
see your name on the board and you're
not playing I don't think it sort of had
a word I said look mayor there's a way
to leave someone hours but particularly
a senior professional but I don't I
think it's exactly saying whether you're
a young kid or whether you're an old
professional is a way of telling someone
they're not playing not to walk into a
dressing room and find out on the team
sheet on the board in front of everyone
and that's how each other that's how I
myself and big dunk found out we were
left out and it was even worse after
that because the result to one
he put big dunk on before me and then
put me on for the lust so fifteen or
twenty minutes and then we finished the
game obviously angry go home watched
much of the deer and then of course it
was mine and Duncan's fault for and that
that would been beaten according to
route on TV Jesus so I thought that was
it that was the
the final nail if you like to say well
I've got to do something about it here
and so I went in Bryan early got the
kids up an hour earlier than they should
have been to school drop them off at
7:45 which is unheard of the doors
weren't even open I left the modern kids
I'm sorry I've gotta leave you in so I
drop the kids in and go racing down the
walkway in the car and pull into the
training ground and luckily I've seen
cars in there so I'll go personal into
the office and I look in and they're big
dogs already beat me to it
they're tearing strips off the wall
before and it wasn't some of you it was
I was assuming he definitely wouldn't
want a bagel big dogs house that's for
sure no I can't anything no very short
lived but a great partnership yeah and
like what was she running like Domon
first off when you're feeling like God
nor defense that's got to look forward
and this like anything listen that was
the goal of volley score the gratin
oddly he was he was as hard as they come
big donkey if he said jump jump jump tie
of course you haven't very very good
like that but he was hard as nails yeah
so that was it and then he resigned or
was sacked whatever I'm not I'm not
quite sure and then Bobby Robson the
rest is Sir Bobby Bobby and this with
Bobby came in um I mean he saved
he saved my curry and a black and white
shirt definitely probably saved my
career because he got me smiling again
he got me enjoying football something
simply just said to me it's look you're
making it too easy for the sender half's
everything's gone towards the halfway
line rather than going the other way you
know asking enough questions of the of
the to centre after you've got you've
got to be horrible to play against again
you're too easy
there's something as simple as that and
then in his first home game against
Sheffield Wednesday we scored it I
scored five and then that was it I was
back
back up and running again so but so
Bobby was it was a genius at man
management it's incredible whether
you're a 17 year old kid or whether
you're a 35 year old experienced
professional he was it was brilliant it
again the best and making you feel good
making you feel special Megan you enjoy
football he was just incredible
even even watching his interviews and I
think this goes for all football fans
with a new customer or not you fell in
love with him like he just had such a
passion when you come across such a nice
person
yeah yeah he was like the grand out of
English football no I was the only heat
head it achieved so much before that
fourth choice for him to come back to
his Northeast what you did to manage his
Football Club you could see the passion
that and the love that he had for the
for the football club I mean he took us
from bottom of the Premier League and
Champions League football and in a very
short space of time and he used all his
experience to do that was evident when
they were talking to him because he he
discovered or named Ronaldo that I would
he'd manage boss'll order and he took I
switch to the controller could you could
you tell me all that beautiful he yeah
he told me the story that when I was
leaving Blackburn he drank Blackburn up
whilst manager of Barcelona hmm and said
that we want to by Alan Shearer and
Blackburn had told him in no uncertain
terms that I wasn't for sale at all at
any price and forget about it he says
and then the next thing he knew I was
signing for Newcastle
but it didn't turn out too badly for in
us and in designing and not signing me
signed Ronaldo so it wasn't didn't work
out too badly for me
when Sir Bobby passed away I noticed
there was an interview with Kieron Dyer
who just got the news and he was really
upset like hey mister he was like I feel
like my second dad sort of just passed
away like I look up there was so much to
feel a lot of the Newcastle players
would have felt the same yeah oh
definitely yeah because that's that's
the way he was with with players when as
I said whether you're a kid or whether
you
thirty-five-year-old been around for
years he made you he made you feel
special but he also he also made you
feel as if how lucky you were to be a
footballer because he'll go back to his
background or where he was from mid
Durham the mines etc etc and so he was
he was always constantly drumming that
into you and you just had huge respect
for him you know
huge loss term couple of stories about
players who said you know because he
comes from such a nice man but he had to
have a bit of a nasty streak about him
to be a boss like he's still a manager
then you've got a silver speck of
another and these young players and he
thought some names musical ever there
was a few stories where he was like do
you know a well-managed regal Ronaldo
you're an ant
Conte oh yeah he definitely had that
side to him if he if he needed to and
because of where he had been and who
he'd managed before you when when he
showed it then you had to listen and he
definitely had the I know there was
there was players at times that let him
down with fighting on the pitch or
whatever yeah or disciplinary things
that happened it was a lot of nice
Salvatore only under his watch because
it was definitely a lot of were the
younger guys with Knights out yeah this
that's a I mean a young guy coming to
Newcastle single a lot of money there's
a lot on offer and I think a lot was
taken by the youngsters by the younger
boys yeah hmm
Kieron Dyer actually has much and tried
the Baja beach club yeah yeah you've got
some really good clubs in you must be
whenever you say maybe love I always
think that's us I wouldn't know
yeah you got some friends you know very
well I've been in the club for years God
not a new customer you're on the come up
and uh Bobby you in the Champions League
no but we belong and what did pretty
well when the Milan couple Asim that was
a great night line in Milan yeah scoring
two goals in the in the Sancerre or they
atmosphere Madden or what how many
thousands of funds that were there when
you Castle twelve or fifteen thousand
whatever behind that behind that girl in
the San Siro it was a brilliant
atmosphere a great game to play and I
think we were the first team ever in
Champions League history to lose the
first three games but still qualify here
I think the others we got that we got
the results and in the end the remaining
games to see his qualify so well that
team as it was like it was a good
mixture because you had like lead us
like you know yourself and Gary speed
and people like that but you also had
the young lads with pace like Dyer and
Bellamy and and Nobby Solana with a good
ball in like they have everything going
forward no it was good it was a good
team to play as good fun you still you
know wouldn't you if you're not having
fun and there's no point been they're
not that's sometimes when you look at it
is that sometimes Billy as you see that
you're not having fun there but you've
got you've got to enjoy it and that's
what you're doing every single day your
life is football so you have to enjoy it
you have to love it and that was what
what financially said there was he made
football fun for you again he put a
smile back on your face and also make
him face up against centre backs again
yeah what do you think you are like to
play against
hopefully I was well I know I was
horrible to play against but I was
taught to do I was taught you don't get
anywhere by being nice and in football
though I think you'll get walked on yeah
people will walk wall over you've got a
big Center offs behind your kicking you
pull on your scratch in you
whatever T in year okay them so you have
to look after yourself
definitely I always gave as good as I
got house I was hard most of the times I
was fair but now I was a senior affair
with Neal and agree with that I he
deserved age he was stupid forehead but
my fault it was just meant it was just
cooked oh I didn't mean to kick him when
they had obviously I just kicked out cuz
it but I didn't and then so panicked
when I knew he'd had bored my foot yeah
still fair so there are people talk is a
one of your master date imagine right
always talks about how much he used to
love chatting to people on the pitch
yeah
Michael dealers rates of to breed tells
great stories about variety just really
yeah laning by the metal had a hell of a
bulb love watchin lovely well I was
assuming it's funny you know when you
won because once you retire you come
across in the media you work for
different channels and different people
and then you come across all these
players who you thought I don't really I
hate him I don't like him he's oral to
play against them Peter Schmeichel was
like that we had some great battles like
right he did but over the past three or
four years I've worked with Pierre and
we get on great now I like best buddies
now it's like sponsors in the pictures
aversion yeah but it's not the normal
you know you're in a different state - I
call do you see boxer years we are Tyson
and what is your best mates now
the one player who did have a little bit
of a body which was broken yeah
and knowing you've actually I think you
did a little bit of poetry next song I
did Yeti there I think I didn't FA Cup
game yes oh god would you say anything
to each other no all right we gon we gon
fight what a laugh what a joke he was
another one he had some great battles
with it I really respect in the end it's
in James's Park oh yeah you swallow you
gotta tear when he got that red card it
was funny cuz when he walked off the
pitch and it was because it was the last
minute of the game
on a minute or two left and he'd been
given the red card and he was waiting
for me at the top of the tundra Pentiums
in the course we tried to get to each
other and we couldn't it was like told
me back and they don't know me but but
we couldn't get to each other so would
have been interesting yeah
but personally I think you would have no
of course I would
no you chose to use Desmond and then Oh
what so you kind of go chat to people
out and pitch um
only if they he's just due to say bad
things to me mmm then I was never I've
never went out with the intention I've
seen anything to any send a half at all
yeah it was only if but again as a
center for you also get a chance to have
the last laugh yeah yeah you don't the
the best way they say things is put the
ball in the bucket and and of course on
the way back Billy offer a lie and then
he can give them two barrels so we want
to test with as a player as well of
younger players and ya know I was
brought in in that Southampton team
where there was an old guy Jimmy kiss
who was the senior professional there
was experienced hard as old kneeled as
old boots and he was he looked after us
all as kids and if anyone kicked us he
would go on have a word with him so I
sort of learned a lot from him in that
where I was in trying to look after the
youngsters yeah yeah so the one time I
did really kick off and then you cost
yes and villain game Stevie tail had a
fight with a ball and lady boyo and
q-diode to fight with each other and the
pictures are they you cry band boy I
like talking to well do you know what
you said to him like after that was and
what was going through their mind
something in the dressing room I thought
I was something like what though he's
been doing it was just I couldn't it's
twice that's happened to me on pixel is
that we get up into Wales at Blackburn
grim LeSueur and David batty we played
mas go away in the in the Champions
League they had a fight with each other
on the pitch grandma so grandma saw and
I'm David Bhatia and then the course
Kieron Dyer and Lee boy had they wanted
to Newcastle but they were they were
devastated in the dressing room they
knew they'd let everyone down didn't
knew that more importantly prodded let
so Bobby done I think that was the the
big thing that the unit felt guilty more
than anything isn't that the the
obviously order him an apology and they
did because I had all of her duty I
think were losing 3-1 or something and I
was walking out I'm just gonna call
don't know and I turn around as I'm
walking down the stairs and there's a
good monitor up and I turn on the
fighting on they yeah it was like yeah
as it plays well you must hang around
Stan just what oh yeah oh you see you
get you get angry on pitch obviously cuz
don't know everything cause you're we
get angry with the opposition you get
angry with you with your own players but
it's no way you can do that especially
in front of 50 mm like millions watching
on TV did you honestly know up and
plenty of times in Tremont really I mean
I mean anyway anyway is that like good
like because if someone's I think they
can fight to me I'd rather than made a
lot than just lackadaisical not give a -
right you've got 25 guys who were
training together every day four or five
days a week clear on a Saturday you're
not gonna get everything go smoothly all
the time so it's quite a regular
occurrence to see players fighting on
the training ground I want to knock him
out three total in address room after a
game it is in fact quite common it
certainly was when I was playing a lot
of egos as well yeah well yeah it's it
happens and of course when when it when
it happens as it's it's such people look
at he's a big shot guy there's a fight
on this railing ground book its life it
happens everything you lose your
brilliant drums up and down the country
yeah there was one play I brought about
you in this book great poem who you
played on the Bobby Robson era
I'm not scared I have a big tough guy
and all that in the part of the attacks
of Max in there don't come up in
Newcastle miss if you know what's good
for a text yeah text off him once yeah I
can't even what the text said you press
send and I thought warned us he do in
sleep he seemed to claim that you'd done
an interview where you were plus in the
both good that's what he said after same
all Island passing them up in them you
wanna look at how lovely yourself for me
as something along those lines and you
said that you'd knock them out a feeler
from Buddy Media festival
have you seen them since then I haven't
seen them for a while to be honest no
you've been in New Castle Island
yeah yeah yeah what was once and
McDonald said I am I thinking cheese I
say is tiny it's his shoes
is such a small man Hollywood the to is
we had it on the pitch we were very good
for each other actually because
obviously in the latter stages with my
career I've started lose a bit of
Pearson for what I lacked he made up
with that he was Christ finish and so
you only all the goal so on the pitch it
was it was decent on the picture he
annoys me a little bit crepe bother
maybe also because he goes on to Aryan
because all you Castle funds yeah this
thing that the clothes should be as big
as a little pool and my United I'm not
sure Greg well then I won't know any
television form it well you are you for
real
talk and I said [__] he enjoyed but he
enjoys that sort of being a little work
being an attacking being antagonistic
yeah yeah but then obviously you were
also I think you know captain living and
went back and went off yeah kicking
somebody's missing only yeah that's
another time where you probably turn
around for did you even know what
happened to that not really no not on
the not on the pictures 98 World Cup
wasn't against Argentina I wasn't really
aware of what had happened and I was
captain but I think we there was nothing
really said in the dressing room after
that I think everyone was just Norman
still in shock at losing it and to the
penalties look we've all done things on
a pitch that you think I wish I hadn't
had done that or I should have done it
differently so it's very difficult to
have a go as someone where do you know I
mean because ever everyone's human on
these everyone makes mistakes now and
again do you member his reaction to that
and we you because obviously after he
got hammered no substitute he says he
some really value that he almost lost
his career no I should great character
come on but yeah coming back from that
because a lot of players would have
folded with the treatment that that was
dished out to him after that yeah that
was when the press or showed that
because you when you know anyway I think
the first time I remember the press
getting angry and managers and players
getting stick which was a lot which is
the Bobby Robson here in 1991 ish
something like that on 1990 Bobby Robson
got a lot of a lot of stick and I just
thought it's it's it's started big-time
and I think it was a wrong about then
that got it started yeah
I went that much like the documentary
about like because obviously I wasn't
old enough to remember but because to me
were Austin's like this well-respected
manager who nobody who really would
question because that's because you
overcame all that but I didn't realize
they really try to make him into a joke
really quite disrespectfully isn't it
that's when I can put it first on or get
angry
managers and players was wrong about
that timing did you ever think of
leaving a moment mental there was to
think well I'd leave England did you
ever think of just leaving England
anyway in your career going somewhere oh
I had opportunities but I never it was
never a huge desire to go abroad no it
was I was lost I was always quite
content a chance to go to Italy which
team to which team a Bari Sampdoria at
the time but it never there was nothing
big enough for me to say yeah I want you
to go and follow that lead up because I
was always quite content in in England
yeah that's interesting as well because
a lot of people get a serious huge yeah
it was really opens a bar in Sampdoria
now they're not the same no again they
were there a big to me yeah the point of
these teams in it
yeah later in your career obviously we
had the Graeme Souness Iran and things
just went downhill for Newcastle you
came back tried to save the day at the
end and unfortunately I think the ship
was already probably sunk by that point
a lot of mentally weak corridors and the
dressin that's been polite I'm here not
really to be honest I think the second
team that got relegated while she would
have said that - yeah it's not saying
something but um you did your best to
try to say were at the end there you
were in helped about things joy bottom
got sent off a little brother I remember
you'd always been so perfect than your
responses to questions and that was the
first time I thought always were really
pissed off yeah like this is Lucas and
Joey was injured for the first four
games that I was there for I was there
for eight games or Joey was injured for
the first four so I only had him for the
last four games and he had he had legs
and we had Kevin Nolan on Nicky book in
the team who were great professionals
give everything but they couldn't go up
and down the pitch Joey could so I'd
said to him about going back to
Liverpool and the issues that he'd that
he'd had there would he be all right
handle in the atmosphere because he's
going to get hammered off the crowd and
he said yet no problem won't let you
down so we put him in who started him
and we were getting beat three nil and
to be honest that was a great result
should have been ten they hit the pause
five or six timesand and we're just
about to take him off and then in front
of the cop who tries to size Chevy
Alonzo doll straight red card suspended
till the last three games of the season
so I had him for one six to sixty
minutes when it was yellow
he let me down he let the club done
and then I just thought it was it was my
time to say a few home truths and I did
in the Dressman told him what I thought
told him what everyone else was thinking
and saying and that was it I never I
never saw him again after that way he
just didn't come back today now in one
bucket okay what was it like being the
monitor over that period of time because
it's a different kind of pressure and
you know you're really your whole period
being able to affect things a lot more
and now you're having to live through
these lads who aren't as good as what
you were and so many top pros of said
it's hard to do that because you having
to deal with people who can't just do
what you want to get out there and do no
I think what disappointed I mean most of
Newcastle was a lot of the attitudes I
didn't get everything I felt I could
have out of some players at Newcastle
that particular time it was hard it was
disappointing I worked my socks off for
rare for the a games but it was also a
learning curve and a great learning
curve and I still had the the hunger and
the desire to go into management I still
thought I would have after that and
obviously I thought it was going to be
it to be at Newcastle but for whatever
reason it didn't it didn't work out
but even after that I still thought I
was gonna do it but then after time the
longer you're out the more difficult it
is to get back in I started enjoying the
media a little bit more I just thought
no I'm gonna knuckle down and get stuck
into the media and that's what I want to
do because it's it's a great life here
that must be a bit easier I mean you've
seen Oman each other age now myself but
I enjoyed the responsibility I mean
you've got to make so many decisions
what there were stupid things like what
are they where what are they eat what
are they what time you got on me I mean
everything you're basically a dad to 25
guys they're all different edges and you
whatever anyone says you have to treat
them differently you can't say well this
is the group it's black or white he
either do all doing this you all doing
that everyone has different needs
everyone has different personalities so
you got a treat guys slightly different
to what you'd normally do to one guy you
got to do different to the other so it
was an eye-opener but it was something I
enjoyed did you find yourself reaching
back into memories of stuff that you'd
have with Kenny and you kept it very
long but you know people that Bobby as
well and trying to work out what they
was right - yeah absolutely and spoke to
sport - to a couple of them also just to
try and get a little bit of feedback
from from them but ultimately it boils
down to that is the players weren't good
enough yeah attitudes weren't good
enough and there wasn't enough Drive and
hunger to keep Newcastle in the Premier
League did you think that was understood
by everyone in the media because I
remember that was when I was I was sort
of first starting to go a football
blocking and things like that and I was
probably one of the people that I've
seen and that team because they didn't
come across as a great sight but do you
think people saw everything that went on
and rightly some summarise the one thing
that stands out from mine I knew that it
would be difficult from the start is
that my very first dear I was aware of
issues obviously yeah what were going on
inside the football club I was aware
that people are walking off train and
for no reason I was aware that people
were late for training so what I did the
first day was I put a fine system in
because my very first day there there
was a member of staff lid so I thought
that was a warning sign so I put a fine
system in the first time you lay it was
10% you ages the second time you lose
25% and the third time you lose 50% but
you had to get that passed by the
players committee in the players
committee as soon as the fine system hit
the dressing room floor the players
committee came and knocked on my door
and said that's not acceptable we don't
want that and my answer was well don't
be late
I'm asking you just be in for training
at 10 o'clock you will start at 10:30 I
promise you for the next eight weeks
you'll be in the training ground for no
longer than 130 and that's including
lunch it's not as if you're in London
where you could get stuck in traffic I'm
asking to be in training ground at 10
o'clock to start at 10:30 and that
wasn't allowed to put the fine system in
the PFA wouldn't allow it and the
players committee wouldn't allow us so
then I thought there's an issue here
yeah because if if players don't just
don't believe it's simple yeah but I
wasn't allowed to do it so I knew I knew
it would be difficult from then onwards
yeah and it must be good though to know
that you do have the phone number of
someone whose experiences I didn't know
any good do it yeah but you still trust
those though you still got people
now I think even even now I mean we even
with rude brutally who I get on great
with now it's the same situation I think
right throughout my career that I think
any manager that I've played for I could
pick the phone up to them now and have a
conversation with them I'll go for a
point with them and I think that's
important and I think that says a lot
about Who I am and who they are also mmm
what was it like dealing with my gosh
really in that time I only saw him twice
once was after the middlesbrough key and
when we beat Middlesbrough at home and
the other time was two days after we'd
been relegated to talk about what
happened and to agreement going forward
that I was gonna manage the Football
Club and then I shook hands and said
okay see you later I'll see you next
week however and I haven't spoke or seen
him since those how he loved the idea of
the fine system what astounds me about
my gosh this owners made so much money
in must have intelligence about them in
order to do that is how long I mean he
still isn't grasped the concept of how
football works even now like I am amazed
is someone who register a regular blog
like you have to invest in somebody you
have to you know give the manager the
funds you need something for him to make
the same mistake this season and whether
offer manages to squeeze the season that
would keep us up or not like it will be
out of ruffles ability in the players
trying hard and not through him helping
them I think that I think an issue is is
is knowing the area and knowing the
Football Club on understanding the
Football Club and loving it mm-hmm and I
think that's where he that's where he
probably falls down is that doesn't
understand the Football Club or the area
and actually what it means what the
Football Club means to the people
because you know and I know that the
difference between having a good week in
a bad week in new customers what happens
on a Saturday afternoon is in James's
Park people
work hard all week to spend their money
on two things one is having a good time
and the other is watching Newcastle
United and if they have a good time and
you casters successful that's a great
week for the people in you caster and he
probably doesn't understand but he when
he comes up with things like I'm not
going to be able to compete with
Manchester City I'm like do you really
think anyone in Newcastle expects up
well you know I mean like spend 20 30 40
million I don't you can't tell me he
hasn't got the capability to do that but
he wants to put it out like it's
impossible to do that last Bournemouth
spent 20 million on one player they've
got like 10,000 people watching them
every week yeah that's that's that's
exactly right is that when you look at
how much you bomb will spend on here
individual player or Leicester you can
go through seven eight clubs who were
probably and the same size as Newcastle
now as in where they should be in the
league as in spending terms and nothing
that's the frustrating thing is is that
you see these guys spending 20 25
million on on one player whereas that's
the total budget for Newcastle and
that's the frustrating thing but after
all it's his money but if he doesn't
want to be there then yeah yes I'll say
it's that he has a responsibility
towards that yes he knows yet what is
his money but if he doesn't want to be
there and if it doesn't want to spend
then let someone else come on in you let
someone else take it over do you have
any contact yes yeah yeah now speak to
speak to Rafa Rafa when he first signed
he got me and after the first a second
day and asked about the Football Club
about the area what I felt needed
changing or doing and
I give him I told him everything
honestly and openly yes so he's been
brilliant
you're very good he is that say that a
lot of media didn't really have a very
fair representation of him when he came
back to England who was what do mean
when he took over Chelsea well I
actually remember Jen there saying to me
when he first took over Chelsea wow I
wish she'd actually gone to some of his
press conferences because I'd have
treated him differently if I'd have
known he was this kinda and it seems
like the the perception of him is
completely changed knowing your own
perception of him has changed no I spoke
to him at the beginning of this season
also he's very frustrated I mean he
didn't tell me anything different than
what he's already allowed to the media
that he has he was pretty angry that
he'd felt that things were promised to
and hadn't been delivered yeah and he
was open and honest and told everyone
about that but I think it was a great
coup Newcastle to get him in the first
place and then for it
to keep hold of him because one you got
to put yourself in roughish shoes also
on think well what else is available
other than Newcastle yeah
he's not getting any of the top six job
at the minute yeah and then they
compared the size of the Football Club
what could be available and there's
nothing bigger than Newcastle mm-hmm by
all accounts he loves it in England his
family around the world so that was that
was one of the probably one of the
reasons why he decided to stay because
of the size of the football club and
what he feels he can can actually
achieve and I don't think they'll be
relegated I think because of him because
of experience because of the way they
work that setup hard to be okay
which is the last change yeah I think
he's got a bunch of players that are
willing to listen willing to work hard
and if you work hard in Newcastle he'll
get on that's all the funds ask is that
you put a shift in going back to sort of
just for you obviously management when
when you retired as a player what what
influence that decision I knew that I
couldn't clear the level that I wanted
to fortunate all my career to play at
the highest level yeah and I wasn't was
never gonna be a player that I was gonna
drift on the leagues
friend of mine said to me many many
years ago always get off the stage while
people are sheldon for more yeah and I
was determined not to be this fast guy
who had a decent career rolling around
in the bottom and the bottom tiers of
the league and I'm not saying that's
right or wrong I'm just personally for
me I didn't want that to happen so and I
couldn't I couldn't I knew I couldn't
get to the standards that I wanted to
continue to to get to so I had to retire
I was gonna retire a year early actually
it was um it was grim soonest that
taught me around to do in the extra year
you just said you a long time retired
you still got plenty to offer and I want
you to be part of my team still be the
captain you won't pull every game but
I'm gonna bring players in you can go in
dip in and dip out and I just thought
you know off for a year I think that'll
be all right yeah I ended up playing the
vast majority of the season because I
didn't get in the players that say he
wanted all the players like going
weren't quite good enough and thankfully
that extra year got me the got me the
record the record for with Jackie
Milburn and of course it was fear really
because my last ever kick of a football
in the professional game was start
penalty against Sunderland yeah at the
Stadium of Light obviously I was
retiring at the end but at five or six
games earlier money had gone ago an
injury and was we had to walk off Indian
and never play again but one of my worst
moments in football was missing the
penalty
for Newcastle against Sun a gala gating
and that was always or um down my throat
and uh I was desperate desperate
desperate to get a penalty against
Sunderland
and it took all those years to get one
against Sunderland and ironically was my
last ever kick of a football I don't
know what I would have done I thought I
missed it thankfully it went in the back
of the net so yeah please listen corner
you play still got it cuz there's like
you I don't know who put the video up
but there's a video of you want it near
a pool somewhere I was in England my son
has a thing every year that he wants to
pull about me scoring a goal but yeah
that my son does that yeah yeah he's
fooling us and you photo petrol I mean
it's just the other side of them and you
put a rose between two thorns yeah
that's like what was the first few weeks
like a billion retired from football we
just sitting around I was a few weeks
the first couple of weeks all right
because it's a novelty is that God I
don't have to care about the hospital
train I can eat what I want that and
drink what I want I can I can wake up
with a hangover doesn't matter it's all
grace after four for two or three months
after you've after you've retired and
then the guys go back in the preseason
in July and then you start sort of
twiddling your thumbs and and then they
can watch you star which is the hard
thing then it's difficult it's difficult
because from the age of 15 to the age of
nearly 36 you've had everything done for
you all you've ever known is get up go
at Raymond
sometimes 2:00 in the afternoon get home
prepare work for a Saturday every summer
got watch what you do watch ye and keep
on taking over training and for 20 years
that is it D and do and then all of a
sudden I see it gone you know no longer
part of the football club football club
will one year and you're on your own
any sympathy I'm not you know no one's
ever loved them for simply because
you've been feeling great weird you felt
it but all of a sudden you just go and
then as I said earlier about the
adrenaline rush whatever you do in your
life you're never gonna get that rush
back on the scoring a goal or walk
around from the 80,000 or captain in
your country or captain and Newcastle
and that's why a lot of players get in
in the troll I said because the gory it
cheat and that drug and that's not there
you didn't do that well luckily I was
fortunate because I saw I went from one
dressing room into another one as in
much of the day with Hanson and lineker
and Lee Dixon and righty and all the guy
saw I sort of left that one but went
straight into another one yeah and that
was all enough so it's it must be very
very difficult for the guys who have
gone from the dressing room into nothing
every witness that happened to other
footballers where he is a parent it
happens all the time yes I mean every
every year happens that someone finishes
playing football and then they're just
left you one thing I'd like to talk
about the story of me because I've known
someone close to me commit suicide
before and I wanted to talk about
carries speed obviously not what
happened but like it's it's harder than
a normal death in a way because it's the
questions and all of that and how did
you deal with losing such a good friend
and no it was very difficult because I
was with him the dear before he did it
mm-hmm and everything seemed fine we
were he was arranging to come to my
foundation ball a day earlier so he gon
play golf and he's gonna stay at my
house and this was all on this Saturday
he had done Football Focus in the
morning and I'd spoke to him in the
engine and then and I was doing much
they day on the evening so he sat
together and discussed and all of that
he told me he was going out on the night
zone
I get home it did much the day I get
home at 3 o'clock in the morning turn my
phone up to silent and then I wake up a
bit and then on 9 o'clock and I have 20
or 25 missed calls off for good friend
Aires and I just thought because I'm
here Alan I'm always first in someone's
falling I thought someone boom dialed me
so I rang him up I said to him he pissed
again last night you've been ringing me
20 times and that's when he delivered
the air then used to me that so you're
not going to believe this is Speedos
done what he did and then it's
incredible it was tough hard as a fan of
speed or because he was one of the
favorites of the club watching you go
under the pitch with his sons I heard a
lot respectfully for doing not like
because obviously those lots of feel in
the way the feeling and your son and
with them you know I don't know because
I don't have had experience with death
before but like someone who's your age
it's it's an Italian dish today it was
say it was just so hard to take I mean
old for me but you can imagine a pianist
his family went through and the and the
two boys on his on his missus and his
mum and dad
sister so know was it was it was a tough
time very difficult we we go on great we
wish to go on a golfing holiday every
year and south speed or Shay Given
mm-hmm Steve Harper Terry McDermott hmm
so we got we were great friends and it
was - it was just to complete and not a
shock it was just incredible it couldn't
couldn't believe it
no it was it was a tough time you took
you know doing a documentary I think on
is a concussion it is there a link
between heading a football and dementia
yes when you look around the the guys
who have a suffering from it and who
have suffered from it the numbers seem
extremely high to the general public and
we seen more and more we saw in America
I watched the film concussion yeah and
that's how I saw go into it with memory
loss I haven't got a great memory
anywhere never had and I just thought
it's struck with me that a lot of the
more than half of the sixty-six World
Cup winning squad had or suffering from
it Jesus so I just thought the numbers
and there's something not quite right
here so I went to the BBC and asked them
who could look into it more and then we
have been so we were actually coming to
the end we've done our last bit of film
and knowledge God do some voiceovers and
then that the documentaries coming out
in early to mid November it's really
nice to say this because I know
obviously fight us especially so far
from a lot of these things in them Chris
Benoit the W wrestler they did analysis
on his brain after he unfortunately
killed his wife and himself oh yeah he
said he had the brand of like an 85 year
old man through all the headshots and
everything that he'd taken so I like
there was a lesson because I've been
head the ball some names when he had a
really hard case are you Jesus Christ or
not we do another case well Jeff a still
died and his brain was was diagnosed
with having CTE which is an industrial
disease and they said it was from
heading a football that was in 2002
three so we go back and look at that and
we actually examine the the brain in the
in the documentary and then we look at
different players who were so from
suffering from it now and whether there
is a link to actually heading it or not
because the band heading football in
America for under 11 s yeah because of
that there's a lot more awareness
America though isn't it because
obviously NFL's massive I think you
start there in general there are a lot
more so health and safety conscious yeah
do you after do this documentary and
sort of come to the end of it do you
feel in a similar way or do you sort of
see it in the same however the results
of what we've what we found yet because
we have to the program was not yet mid
to its early to mid November yeah but
it's it's it's been ever it's been an
eye-opener being really interesting and
difficult at times as well to see what
how how it effects as well but also
their families as well what the families
have to have to go through so we hope
that was doing the documentary will get
the ball rolling to get people more
people talking about it to start the
research and and what-have-you and then
to find a definitive answer yeah because
there's obviously supposed to go you've
had well was i heading was a huge part
of my game and I was taught to do I was
told to do it and um used to practice it
every single day sometimes heading 100
hundred and fifty balls it done it's
done itself out as a kid and it was a
huge part of my game which is one of the
reasons why I wanted to do the
documentary tommysaw like as in a wonder
if this is how I'm gonna have any issues
because of this does yeah that's one of
the reasons why I yeah why I did it
because as I said my memories my
memories hopeless I wanted to find out
whether there was any link there so
alright so got some too
questions for you just to finish off on
then there are some ridiculous ones and
that's that's fine
ray Scott from with email of us reckons
he was your bodyguard is he full of [__]
yes he is full pretty really / yeah then
no funniest funniest to me to go on the
piss with I'm funny his teammates can I
think I'll have to be Robley good lad we
got some good times
what about best golf umpires the best
golfer I'm gonna say the best the best
round the golf that I've been power was
she a given - nope still under the
influence from the night before off off
a beam and shooting 51 points okay Wow
with a shank off the first tee so I was
asking well hurricane bring your record
he's got a chance
barring injuries and whether he's gonna
stay at Tottenham an artbook you'll have
a shiner team as well as you Newcastle
we saw it didn't work but also injuries
I mean if you go through how are you
career nowadays with the pace of the
game on the number of games without
having one serious injury then you're
fortunate so I mean I had three so I had
someone else's as well I think do people
often ask you what you'd be like in
nowadays Premier League yeah I still be
the same re-keying would have been the
same 20 years ago
all I got the if you're a girls go here
find a way yeah who annoys you more so
much of the deer who annoys me most on
much of the deer I'm not gonna see a
righty because we just laugh all day
with with righty who annoys me most
monkian same as he did when I was
playing against him yeah we met Martin
killed him like on the shoot a while but
it liked what it saw Sofia everything's
really is sincerely sincere about
absolutely every sandwich I had a great
sandwich one is like I've gotta tell you
about this is real I support memory Tony
mitosis but yeah I kind of like the soul
of his voice it's cool
Susan he's quite see thing you know that
maybe that's why I fall asleep too much
the thoughts on Blackburn since Chuck
Walker's pasta actually the Saint use of
ticking the moon devastated to see them
where where they are and how they are
this its moment in time when you compare
the club won we won the Premier Li to
the club now it's it's just incredible
to see what's and what's happened I just
hope it changes for the for that area
for the people because I know what it
means to to the people that who support
the Football Club and it's a great
Football Club a block grant fund still
love you like the oldest Dale was doing
between in a lot as well like yeah I get
I had four great years and of course
that's the only place where I wouldn't
want my trophies the Premier League so
at great times we're still amazing to
think you've won a Premier League title
with Blackburn boys and you say this is
very surreal mud when you compare that
to where the owner was some terrible see
it's a shame because they are critical
we had one ask would you swap the
Premier League with Blackburn to have
like an FA Cup with Newcastle oh that's
unfair question I am we all know the
outside yeah did you really chain Keith
Gillespie yes that he's really opened up
since he got over a lot of the issues he
had or whatever so yeah he was he was
been a bit of a p.m. on like mmm-hmm
repeatedly
sorry but some roses to freeze okay so
you didn't actually use the checks it
looks powerful no I caught him somewhere
on the Jenna thing but and chin doing
the best side you ever played him it
would have been that 90169 he must've
got pretty clear was brilliant it was it
was great and and and the 9018 that well
me were unlucky against Argentina when
Beck's was sent off there were two great
teams Club wise I was difficult to say
that one at Blackburn was incredible as
I said to take on the big boys but when
I came to Newcastle that team going
forward with Ferdinand Gianola Beardsley
Gillespie on on one side again it was
very much like the like the Blackburn
team bought 96 team and in the uhm me
Josh was pretty special link biggest
setback you've had in your life if
there's anything that stands or three
injuries yeah three kept me out for
probably misses yeah to and our seasons
maybe three seasons of football because
of my injuries yeah but you can't do
anything about that our support
anyone from the Newcastle team currently
who may be one the younger players who
look I don't think he might make it like
he might become one of the really good
players in the Premier League not yet
not yet no and that's been one of New
Castle's problems is that the lack of
talent they've been able to bring
through over the years that they're the
youth systems been non-existent really
other than help you sort of it's
anyone's guess you until shoulder you
know when you look at their lack of kids
that have come through when you compare
it to thirty years ago when all those
players been coming through and it's
incredible lights and the lack of talent
goes you know kids are still playing
football or what what's change maybe a
shift in emphasis is Robin but you will
discover that something because you
could have a scouting system so long we
could have a skeleton system in
Newcastle and could take players from
New Year's and down to Southampton where
of course that's very much that's
different icons what do you think it may
help me know X is quite he's had he's
had a good start funds like him yeah
good on the ball tidy yeah he's had a
good start graphically like his bit of
visionary Alonso time well yeah yeah
last thing I just want to ask is how'd
you like the be remembered how would a
that's a good question and thank you I
use on every someone who worked hard who
cared who give a little bit back that's
awesome a last thing I wanna see is when
I was 10 years old me mum bought as both
the tickets to go and see a new customer
curio just like you described yeah and I
built this whole book me or life of like
when everyone see Newcastle Shearer I
was going to scored it was it an FA Cup
Killians charm I think it was the
miserable much I think he only just
signed and got extra time it was one one
nothing I mean my mom cares about
full-time work on the half hour and
homes were gonna stay free carry KQ top
corner understand I was in the John Wall
everything goes black cuz now I can't
see anyone because everyone's too tall
for us but you may have got married it's
one of the happiest ones I've got me
life from it good luck so it makes you
appreciate you thanks very much thank
you guys very much no problem you saw
thanks to coral and for sponsored me and
others yeah let's be fair any enzyme put
this one together so thank you very much
as I said if you want to bet with them
our link is in the description below
don't forget to like this video stay
subscribed to the true Charlie YouTube
channel and we'll see you later